[تصفيق]
ادخل
ولا هو مش فاضي لي دلوقتي انا طول عنده
شغل
سواء موضوع مهم جدا
بابا بلاش ان حضرتك ينفع تناقش معك في
الموضوع طيب بعدين يا ابني بعدين هو موضوع
مهم وعايز راي حضرتك بعدين ماشي بعدين
يعني ما ينفعش خلاص يا ابني بعمل حاجه
مهمه في ايه بعدين ماشي لو قاطعتك لازم
يعني مش عارف استنى دلوقتي طب في ايه اكيد
داخل بحاجه تافهه اللي انا بعمله ده مهم
اطلع بره
محكمه
تخيلوا معي وجه هذا الابن
وخيبه امله
وكسره قلبه
اسئله الدنيا قد تدور في ذهنه
هو انا لما دخلت على بابا
وكان بيعمل حاجه مهمه فعلا اهم مني اهم
انه يسمعني
هو انا مستحقش الحب والتقدير
هو في حاجه اهم مني
ولا كل حاجه اصلا عنده اهم مني
لقد ملاؤه الشعور بالخزي
شاب في مقتبل العمر تربى في بيئه خصبه من
الخوف والهجر ارض نبور خاليه من الحب
والاهتمام والتقدير
في موقف كهذا يريد التحرر والتمرد فيسوقه
عقله الى اصحاب السوء
الاصحاب الذين يتفاخرون بينهم ايهم الاجرا
على الفعل الابشع
من منهم الاكثر ايذاء لفتاه وثقت فيه
فتفنن في استغلالها واحراجها
من يريد ان يخرج من دائره الصواب والخطا
اللا قيود التحرر المطلق
يذهب اليهم ليعالجوا المه وخيبه امله
بالتسكع والملهيات
فيبادر اليه اسوا ما فيهم اصيعهم امسك دي
دي هتنسيك هم الدنيا
لا لا ما ليش في الحاجات دي يا عم امسك دي
تفاريح وبعدين احنا مهندلين الموضوع ما
تخافش امسك بس لا اللي هيحصل حاجه
يحصل ايه ما تنشف كده امسك بس بص انا هاخد
بس
نفس واحد
امسك نفس واحد اه
فشري بقى ثم شرب وشرب حتى ازداد في نهمه
كانه ينتقم من ضعفه من نفسه من ابيه من كل
الحياه في هذه الجرعه
حتى يصل الى اعلى درجات الهروب من واقعه
فيصل الى الجرعه الزائده
فيسقط مغشيا عليه
يتوقف نفسه
ويتعطل قلبه
ثم تخرج روحه
تخيلوا معي ماذا يفعل هؤلاء الذين صدروا
له انهم
ملوك هذا مشاورات يملاها الرعب
يتفقون
على ماذا يتفقون على رمي جثته على الطريق
هؤلاء هم اصحاب السوء
يشجعونك على الفعل في بادئه
ويتسكعون ويهرعون ويمزحون حتى يصلوا الامر
الى الجد
فيهربون
في المشهد المعتاد علي ان يعلو صوتي واقول
اني اطالب بمعاقبت هؤلاء اشد المعاقبه
ونعم انا اطالب بمعاقبتهم ولكن الا اطالب
بمعاقبه من تسبب في هذا وجعل الابن في
حاله النكراء
واطالب بمن تسبب في تسريب كمل مدخلات
المغلوطه الينا
واطالب بمن تسبب في تسريب هذا السم الذي
يتعاطاه اولادنا
فقد نجد انفسنا في متتاليه لا تتوقف
فالجميع يتحمل المسؤوليه
والكل ملام
[موسيقى]
ومش راضي
صاحبي
اللي ما كانش له اي ذنب انه يقابل واحد
زيه
واحد كل حاجه بيلمسها وتتحول اتراب
بتموت
انا السكينه سرقتني وما لقيتش
كنت عامل زي الطفل اللي عارف الحاجه الغلط
وبرضو بيرجع لها
انا مش عايز اقابل ربي في الحاله دي
اقول له ايه
اقول له ايه لما يسالني انت عملت ايه
بالعمر اللي انا اديته لك
هقول له ازاي هقول له ان انا ضيعته في
حاجات فاضيه حاجات تافهه
حاجات كنت فاكر انها هتحسسني بالدفء والحب
اللي انا كنت ناسيه اللي انا كنت محروم
منه
ارجوكم ادوني فرصه تانيه
فرصه شهر لو اسبوع لو يوم وكل ثانيه فيه
هتستعدي على الساعه
ادوني فرصه عمل حاجه صح حاجه واحده عدله
ولما اروح لربي اقول له يا رب
انا عملت الحاجه دي
ادوني فرصه
ارجوكم ارجوكم
بعد ان استمع الجميع الى هذا الشاب
والذي استفاضى بالندم
واعترف بكل فعل سيء قد ارتكب
اسمح لي يا ريس اخرج من عباءه المحامي
عشان بجد مشاعره لخبطت
انا مش عارف الوم مين او اعاتب مين بالظبط
قال لهم ادم اللي لما حصل له موقف
كانه بينتقم من الشخص اللي اذاه بدل ما
يتحمل المسؤوليه فكان النتيجه انه يحصل له
كده
ولا لهم سامر الصديق اللي المفروض لما
اروح له يسمعني وينصحني
لكن هو ما عملش كده استغل ضعفي واداني
السن عشان يوقعني في نفس البؤره اللي واقع
فيها
ولا لوم الاب
الاب يا ريس
الاب المفروض السند والامان
للاسف مسك في نغمه انا بعمل كل ده ليه
عشانكم طيب ما هو ابنك جاي يتكلم معك
اسمعوا
التربيه الحقيقيه في الحب والامان
والتقدير والتقويم مش ان انا امن له
مستقبله لا اصل انا بعمل كل ده عشان اعمل
لك مستقبلك ماديا العاطفه والسمع اهم
بكتير جدا
انا بجد مش عارف الوم على مين
اخيرا يا ريس
البناء دايما صعب
ومهمه بناء انسان اصعب واخطر واعظم حاجه
احنا عايشين فيها ليه
كل كلمه وكل فعل
بتاثر جدا في بناء هذا الانسان
زي ما كل فعل وكل وكل كلمه ممكن تهدم هذا
الانسان
في الاخير عايز اوجه رساله
لكل اب
وكل ام وكل ابن وكل صديق
ايه الحاجه
اللي نعملها
عشان ما يكونش بينا سامر او ادم جديد
وشكرا